so Vlad yeah they're heroes they're
being honored we here in aspect I love
the word spectacular in a spectacular
way what you got
it is indeed spectacular gala of first
responders and medical staff are being
honored with some high-flying tributes
so check this out those are at 16
fighter jets flying over a hospital in
Aiken South Carolina yesterday the
state's Air National Guard also flew
other over other hospitals in the region
and we're seeing other units do the same
across the country
pilots put on an airshow over hospitals
in San Diego on Friday and later today
the United States Navy and Air Force
will perform a flyover in parts of New
York New Jersey and Pennsylvania to
salute frontline workers Tony just a
reminder that these are not air shows
they are quick flybys that will just
last a few seconds people should not
congregate but it is very cool that is
the Blue Angels and the Thunderbirds
doing this together very cool and I
agree people should not congregate but
if it's in the air and I'm looking at it
it's an airshow it counts as far as I'm
concerned have you've actually been up
in one of those I did a piece for CBS
this morning a couple of years ago where
I had the honor and the privilege of
going up with an with a Blue Angel it
was an incredible experience at the very
end I did not throw up but I did not
pass out except for a brief moment where
my tongue logged out of my mouth just
like Winston but it was a great time
social media that we appreciate the
honesty Vlad now Pentagon the Pentagon
it that's attracted I'm sure glad I can
make anything look good